sur le terrain semble être arrivé à un
point critique de nombreux pays
occidentaux on va reparler ont
d'ailleurs prié ce week-end leurs
ressortissants de quitter le pays alors
que le chancelier allemand engagé 1 ce
matin un nouveau round de pourparlers
vous le voyez ici au moment de son
arrivée à kiev ces olaf scholz qui va
marcher aujourd'hui et demain dans
l'ehpad emmanuel macron il est attendu à
moscou
ce mardi il est donc à kiev gulliver
crack bonjour vous retrouver sur place
vous êtes notre correspondant en ukraine
la chose qui va s'exprimer un dans
quelques instants lors d'un point presse
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de ceux de
ce rendez vous de ce premier rendez vous
aujourd'hui
alors les pourparlers entre olaf scholz
et le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky sont en cours le chancelier
allemand va sans doute essayer de voir
avec le président ukrainien
s'il est possible de trouver un moyen
d'avancer sur l'application des
protocoles de minsk l'accord de paix si
on peut l'appeler ainsi qu'a été
assignés début 2015 pour essayer de
mettre fin au conflit dont le dôme bas
ce qui oppose l'armée ukrainienne à des
soi disant séparatistes qui sont
soutenues et financées et plus ou moins
contrôlés par la russie mais les chances
de débloquer la situation ne sont pas
grandes les allemands eux mêmes l'ont
avoué puisque l'ukraine a une vision
très différente de l'application de ces
accords que vladimir poutine vladimir
poutine a dit qu'il veut que ce soit
appliquée
dans l'ordre que lui il veut et par
exemple cela voudrait dire que l'ukraine
devrait tenir des élections dans ces
territoires qui sont actuellement sous
le contrôle de ses forces soutenues à
part la russie alors que la russie
contrôlent la frontière alors que la
moitié de la population adulte de ces
territoires a reçu des passeports russes
alors qu'il n'ya aucune liberté de la
presse enfin il y à pas les conditions
pour tenir des élections démocratiques
dans ces territoires et dans ces
conditions l'ukraine maintient elle ne
peut absolument pas accorder une
autonomie assez territoire c'est ce que
l'accord de minsk prévoit mais pour kiev
cela reviendrait à légitimer des forces
qu'elles considèrent comme absolument
illégitime et de donner le cadeau à
vladimir poutine d'avoir un levier pour
contrôler tout le reste de l'ukraine par
le biais de ces territoires devenus
légitimement autonome donc le crâne a
clairement défini ses lignes rouges sur
ces points et il est difficile de voir
où est ce qu'il peut y avoir du terrain
pour un compromis parce que à kiev
l'opinion dominante c'est que vladimir
poutine n'acceptera pas moins que cela
une autonomie pour ces territoires qui
serait plus légères ou les représentants
pourrait être élu d'une manière un peu
plus démocratique selon le gouvernement
ukrainien et la plupart des experts
ukrainiens ne satisferait pas la russie
donc c'est même pas vraiment la peine
d'en parler mais bon peut-être collapse
shops à des propositions qu'on n'a pas
encore attendues entendu l'hiver une
question sur ces appels qui ont été
lancées par de nombreuses chancelleries
occidentales ces dernières heures
appelant leurs ressortissants à quitter
au plus vite le pays l'appel était suivi
et ils suivis d'effets
alors obtenu ambassades ont été évacués
des organisations ont demandé à leurs
travailleurs de partir et c'est
notamment le cas de la mission
d'observation qui observent le conflit
dans le dos de basse les missions
d'observation de l'osce a eu ce qui veut
dire que ce sera très difficile pour
cette mission de continuer de
fonctionner même si dans un communiqué
ils disent qu'ils vont continuer de
fonctionner sinon parmi les civils les
expats à kiev je regarde sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya des messages qui est des
gens discutent de comment partir il ya
certainement un certain nombre qui sont
partis avant-hier j'ai traversé la
frontière depuis la pologne est là les
gardes-frontière mans m'ont dit qu'il y
avait beaucoup de pologne qui quittent l
ukraine en voiture mais de l'autre côté
quand on regarde le tableau de bord de
l'aéroport de kiev et puis entre en
scène s'il est encore possible d'acheter
des billets pour aujourd'hui ou demain
10 billets sont encore disponibles
donc il n'ya pas une exode massive les
gens ne sont pas en train de fuir en
masse en tout cas et cela aussi en
résulte du fait qu ici à kiev pour le
moment tout est calme et beaucoup de
gens y compris beaucoup d'analystes et
d'experts pensent que le scénario où la
capitale où d'autres grandes villes
ukrainiennes seraient bombardées
vraiment un scénario moins réaliste que
le scénario par exemple d'une escale à
sion du conflit dans le dos de bath mais
confiné à l'est de l'ukraine merci
beaucoup d'univers craquements